[Music]
I'm Keith Olbermann and this is the
resistance Sally Yates American Hero
a little over simplistic and in many
respects damning the American government
with faint praise because all she has
testified to the Senate that she did
that she said that happened to her used
to be the minimum standard for public
servants in this country but now in the
era of Trump she stands out like a
champion you are the goddamned president
of the goddamn United States and you're
acting Attorney General tells your White
House Counsel that your national
security adviser was quote compromised
with respect to the Russians quote
essentially could be blackmailed by the
Russians and quote you don't want him to
be in a position where the Russians have
leverage over him and you fire the
acting Attorney General not the National
Security Advisor you fire the acting
Attorney General the person warning you
that a man charged with giving you
arguably the most important advice in
the world what to do to keep this nation
secure from international threat warning
you he's ripe for blackmailing by this
country's primary national enemy a
person of extreme importance in our
white house who can influence you who
could influence you on behalf of the
Russians and you fire her and keep him
which are you an idiot or a traitor what
Sally Yates testified to what Jim
clapper testified to the pathetic
redirections and sad obfuscation of
Chuck Grassley and John Cornyn and poor
Ted Cruz and the other Republican
trumpian lapdogs desperate to change the
subject
desperate to talk about unmasking the
Trump Russia equivalent of saying the
true victim of Watergate was Richard
Nixon because those audio tapes of him
betraying democracy made him sound bad
because people got to hear him swearing
all those expletives deleted all that
was important but the meet of that
Senate committee hearing was the
timeline a cynical disloyal amoral
timeline November 10th
President Obama warns Trump not to make
Flynn his nationals
caridy advisor NBC reports Trump
explains he thinks Obama is kidding
January 26th acting Attorney General
Yates warns the White House that
National Security Advisor Flint has been
compromised by the Russians does so so
the White House can take action January
27th Yates goes back and repeats to the
White House Counsel McGann that Flint
has been compromised and could be
blackmailed by the Russians has lied to
other White House officials and the
Russians know about the conversations
with Flynn January 30th Trump fires
Yates claiming he is doing so because
she would not defend his Muslim ban in
court January 31st Trump does not fire
Flynn February 1st Trump still does not
fire Flynn February 2nd same February
3rd same the 4th the 5th the 6th 7th 8th
9th 10th 11th 12th February 13th the
Washington Post breaks the story of the
Yates warning that Flynn has been
compromised by the Russians and the
Russians could be blackmailing the man
who tells the president how to preserve
our country from destruction by a
foreign power and only then is Flynn for
stout if the post had not broken the
story how long would Flynn have remained
in this White House as Iago pouring
whatever lies the Russians might be
blackmailing him into telling into the
ears of Trump even if Trump is somehow
innocent of everything implied and
inferred about collusion with Russia he
is not innocent of choosing a Russian
stooge a Russian vessel like Flynn and
defending him to the last even to the
point of veiled threats like the one
just hours before that hearing began
Trump tweeted asked Sally Yates under
oath if she knows how classified
information got into the newspapers soon
after she explained it to White House
Counsel this congressman ted Lieu of
california noted there is a law 18 USC
1512 which defines quote intimidation of
a witness to quote influence testimony
in a quote official proceeding as a
federal crime the perpetrator of which
quote shall be fined
under this title or imprisoned not more
than 20 years or both Trump chose
Michael Flynn a blackmailing victim
waiting to happen
over Sally Yates an honest American
public servant On January 26 and he is
chosen Flynn and smeared Yates every day
since
and today he adds intimidation possibly
criminal intimidation to that list once
again if the Washington Post had not
broken this story how long would Michael
Flynn have remained on that job he'd
still be there now wouldn't he
potentially being blackmailed by the
Russians blackmail to influence the
president it is treachery of the highest
order and no matter who is the puppet
and who is the puppeteer our country is
not safe in the hands of these idiots
and Trump and all of them must go and
they must go now resist peace